[Music]
in moment ruined news hmm submitted by
George or is that Jorge whatever you
want is it what a Jay it's what Jay
Goodis joy hey is your geek a woman's
midwife delivered her baby and then
revealed a shocking secret to the new
mom she's having an alien yeah she's not
really emit a midwife it's an Asian baby
and they're not Asian your child is
black and you are white so I need you to
explain this that was my thought process
to you but look I am your eyes want to
keep guessing
no I want to details no I know what it
is to white parents black baby come on
let's go no it's not that it's not a
really a midwife this person was like a
ex-convict no extremity there's like an
extra arm or leg no but these are all
great guesses it's a mid husband and he
busted a nut back into the lady's vagina
the mini Paul the baby oh the baby was
breached and then she was just like
[ __ ] I'm gonna do it let's see let's
see if I came out to the Midwife was
also pregnant they both deliver babies
at the same time oh that would be true
there was a penis and a vagina so it
turns out that this Midwife had an
affair with the dead Oh daddy and then
she told her ads like she was holding
the baby no oh what a [ __ ] so that she
punched in the face cuz she was jealous
she's like you're so lucky I'm so weak
kick your ass
give hug guys like she's so exhausted
from pushing now why does she choose
that moment to do that oh the mom is
holding the baby in the Midwife said I
had enough the Midwife was holding the
Midwife
oh my go be a hostage you better not
hurt me that's why ya know what a sock
the [ __ ] damn I would have punched her
and then caught the baby
yup cat-like reflexes well that guy
cheated on his wife while she's pregnant
that's the best what it told ya so
here's a story oh she sucked his dick
while he was sleeping I hate when that
happens
okay so the baby daddies apparently went
on this vacation on a lads holiday oh
it's in Europe and the
hey laddie during that holiday the baby
daddy met the the Midwife they ended up
having an affair nice to meet you and
then shortly after that affair that's
when the original I'm not sure if
they're married but the mom got pregnant
and then throughout the whole pregnancy
the baby daddy was being a dick and
never wanted to go to the so the
ultrasound appointments not want to be
there for the baby or maybe tough she
missed the birth of his first child
because he was scared of this affair
surface thinking because somehow like
you found out that she was involved in
the same hospital and it became a
coincidence it seems like it's just poor
planning why didn't he get another
Midwife that's his portrait
it was an accident that they met yeah it
seems like that's enough she went to the
hospital and just by chance she so
happened to have this Midwife as the
course of delivering her baby yeah and
then she like spilled beans
mm-hmm that's why he didn't show up
he'll starve oh so he wasn't even there
he wasn't there pieces got all the
appointments that sucks you're missing
out a lot it's really fun you go there
new crying you see oh it's my first baby
my wife better be there [ __ ] no sir this
is [ __ ] creepy we're gonna call a cop
this is not for you
so would you weigh in I'm here for the
sound I paid for the session [ __ ] we
do is yeah but you have a lot of active
kids I'm a gynecologist you have to have
a vagina you know it's crazy - they're
saying that's the Midwife here she also
inserted a suppository this is a mom
where's that one [ __ ] right so it's
like medicine up your butt they're
supposed to go up your butt why should
do that I mean we're supposed to be
positives are ya I don't know like maybe
she needed it but what if it's that what
a visit procedure votive is the
procedure who cares that's a profession
though I know but still the whole like
hey I [ __ ] her so that's what grossed
you out more so that she saw her [ __ ]
bloody ass vagina ripping with this
child
coming out I'm not saying one is worse
than the other I'm just saying like I
just adds to it in my opinion well
here's the thing though did she know
that the dude she was fooling around
with is also married because if she did
know she knew because how are you gonna
go tell someone's wife that you're
sleeping with her husband if you didn't
already know what she looks like
yeah I'm saying that [ __ ] premeditated
some [ __ ] she needs to be cut right
right right
she found out later and she goes I don't
know how to hold this in but I gotta say
it because we're like friends now
they're definitely not me I just had a
kid with your man's right and you found
that out would you would you still try
to make it work because of the babies no
that's so I'm a single mom I can say no
I think I think but it's not find a new
set of friends cuz the circle that she's
around is kind of bad yeah I think it's
easier to say no to if the dude was not
any of the pointman anyway they're alone
anyway yes Church but if the dual is
there every step of the way and I think
it's a little bit could have been busy
at the construction your excuse me know
vicious [ __ ] like he was putting his own
interests ahead of his own for town hey
he had a lot of drinking to do and when
you're pregnant you already are like oh
my body and you're insecure and like to
have your husband sleeping with somebody
else oh yeah he's not easy man to do it
alone
pregnancy is so easy I'm just kidding he
could have been cheating before
pregnancy like it just seems like you've
been cheating all day mm-hmm
and you'd even give a [ __ ] he's like oh
[ __ ] I knocked you up oh [ __ ]
after the mom she wrote a letter to
complain to the hospital and you know to
let them know like this is extremely
unprofessional she never mentioned that
there was a conflict of interest here
she delivered my baby and put a
suppository of my ass so yeah she's
mentioned a suppository up my ass arse
arse oh so they didn't accidentally put
this suppository no no no in her vagine
it went up her ass okay I misunderstood
can you put your own suppository in like
do you have to have somebody do it for
you could do it yourself I do
every day [ __ ] what oh I know cuz when
you senior in my butthole I go inside
every day okay clean I got a clean ball
that's why I don't go to the hospital
there's [ __ ] like this yeah let's see
these guilty asses so this is the
Midwife I only have a motive the Midwife
because she came out on a TV show so hot
custom I might justify why they died oh
so this is Joanne Hey what is real oh
god no blender with that you see her in
the room and you're just like eh oh yeah
yeah she just blends just blend visible
right she doesn't stick out not that
that would make it a meal better my mid
wife just sounds like he mistook that
word as she's also your wife yeah
exactly wanted a funky Mastodon yeah no
wife he's like what the [ __ ] you mean
you about [ __ ] Midwife she he cheated
before she even got pregnant we don't
know there's the three wives the
pre-walk the men were offered a post
wife crucified buddy why don't you yeah
so now that Midwife there's no longer
employed by that hospital she's facing
disciplinary action good she should be
spanked I sound like the bank
bad bad Midwife the mom was singing that
she this Midwife took matters into her
own hands and made sure that she was
present at the birth of her daughter
maybe she cared so circumstances she
like made it so that she was there yeah
okay
and then like crazy
hours average few hours after the birth
that's what she like confesses to her
she's holding her child yeah
while the Midwife is holding the baby
get your [ __ ] filthy [ __ ] hands off
my baby and you're like hella emotional
- like ooh-ahh state it you're right
she's like the mom is just saying like
that's ruined like the birth of my
daughter is she painted it with our
[ __ ] mistress fingers I wish someone
wanted me that bad but then like not
really cuz that [ __ ] is creepy private
she wants the husband so bad like she's
going crazy I want to [ __ ] put a
restraining order on someone no well
what do you want do you want someone to
love you that much do you want a
restraining order what do you want I
don't know sound like a whole like I
feel awesome about better be [ __ ]
Brad Pitt yeah he better be [ __ ] you
know I'm sure he was you you know he's
not Brad Pitt look at the [ __ ]
Midwife then he's ugly inside yeah
that's Jan there's no who knows maybe
she knows how to [ __ ] really glow
when it's off hours true glow i'll get
the pic of glow up after we can we see
it you look at the eyebrows the eyeballs
alone tell you she's crazy
are there any global potential there
even even eyebrows one sticking out
trying really hard like and when she's
smiling there's no emotion your eyes
he's just smiling they're like a
keyboard but I think you guys are biased
because of what she's done cuz she's
crazy she also looks like she has a very
large hunch and a Pucci for a belly oh
yeah yeah she's that's her body cuz it
looked like her postures like that yeah
she has bad posture shows that one of
those [ __ ] yeah she looks like she's
a grandma but not a grandma yet yes you
could tell what she's gonna look like
when she's 60 yeah immediately exactly
she looks like the stereotypical grandma
like if you give her the red I mean the
white curly hair and then the glasses
yeah you know what she looks like she
looks like the old picture of a Civil
War person to survive oh yeah yeah
just put it in buck we're hating on her
because she's [ __ ] yeah she deserves it
no I just hate on her for the way she
looks all right I'll try to be nice
I said let's give her a chance guys but
you convinced me we hate her yeah I I
don't know I think I get a little
jealous that some people obsess over
others like that kpop obsession I feel
like that's what she has and then I
think about the consequences and I'm
like that's nasty to have somebody that
crazy ooh like so crazy she'll [ __ ]
put mercury in your water that's some
crazy [ __ ] fatal attraction mm-hmm
[Music]